[موسيقى]
اذا حدا عنا اي نوع كبه بنساوي فضل الله
بحب شغل كبه بكل انواعه بحب شغل الاكل
والحمد لله رب العالمين انه نحن شاطرين
بالاكل يعني وفضل الله ما حدا اكل عنا
الحمد لله انه اكلنا طيب كبتنا طيبين
[موسيقى]
ام عبد الله ما عندي اولاد يعني عمري فوق
الخمسين من حلب الزياره عن بنت اخوي لهون
والله كتبلي وبيني وبين نفسي ادعي لربي
افتح المحل وسبحان الله يسره وفتحته
[موسيقى]
للحكي فانت ما ترضي الناس ارضي ربك
وكنت كتير مبسوطه فيه وفرحانه كمان
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الله يستر افتح محل هو لحالي
واشتغل فيه والله هي الفكره لاني بحب شغل
الكبه
ورقم كل شغلي ورقم النعم بشتغل والحمد لله
في ناس لحد الان كويسه وبتخاف الله ما
بينسونا من كرامون
[موسيقى]
هو انا الاساس عندي كبه مقليه كبه مشويه
وكبه بسياره والله الحمد لله من جديد انزل
كبه بصينيه بس اذا اذا حدا طلب مني مثلا
غير انواع ضمن الكباب بشتغل يعني هذا بدو
اسمها
[موسيقى]
الله خير
لسه هالحركه ضعيفه بس الحمد لله فيسبوك
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله رب العالمين ربنا
اسكر اروح اجيبه او ثاني يوم اجيبه معي
قبلته
[موسيقى]
عم باسعف ان شاء الله عم بقول يا رب